[Applause]
off in the open court and demar derozan
putting yet another defender on his
highlight reel
that was big time that's how you go top
shelf right there as
beasley gets his 27th point
and demar derozan strong to the rack and
draws the foul
he's mad at the rim there he threw that
down and
go ahead take a couple deep breaths calm
yourself down and
knock down the free throw you threw this
down with authority
another demar derozan special
22 for derozan dj
trying to get into his hot spot refers
to jamar de rosen
and an emphatic dump it's just a
30-point game
he's taking out his chalkboard he's
giving lessons
back to derozan eight seconds demar
makes his move got it tie game
2.7 jamar derozan
a man solomon solomon hill on and one of
their better defenders
but he always creates enough space and
he's just not going to miss that
shot in the paint looks himself
right into his his sweet spot
no ball flake that time derozan
with five derozan two
derozan hits it oh mama
point five remaining demarjo rosen
knocks it down
desperately on this road trip just to
regain some confidence
and demar dancing beautiful step
side step in that mid-range game we
talked about it
for the beginning of the second half
he's just been on
and he hits the bottom 33 for derozan 13
of 25 from the floor
seven of eight free throws shooting five
boards eight assists
and he did he did a great job here bill
another second chance opportunity
good take block joy by zion pals have
numbers
bledsoe he's got the lob for lonzo
he must watch tv when this team turns
defense to offense
say he gets i'm not saying it's a foul
or it's not a foul
what i'm saying is man
i'm sorry that's a good read by bled i'm
sorry i'm still kind of
going on this well where zion's bounced
around
right at the other end and then you're
gonna call it a touch right
he's hit at least two threes in 16 of
their first 23
lonzo boy four-point play he's going to
the line looking for the four-point play
the difference look at his feet when his
feet are set and he won
twos into that three marshall four
seconds left
marshall driving finding ball gets rid
of it in time
it's good lonzo ball with a big three
before halftime to give new orleans a
little momentum
currently stands in the western
conference and also a preview of game
two of our
doubleheader tonight with the nuggets
and lakers eight nothing run by new
orleans to end the first
trying to break down that pelicans
defense maladon
it is oh what an alley-oop there lonzo
ball
set it up for jackson hayes who climbs
the ladder
how about this lob here jackson hayes
a little bit low no problem when you got
hop derrick rose wedged underneath
nice find out to knox rims off
out of three
all the zion climbing
and finishing last possession got an
offensive rebound put back now he's in
transition
the rockets have kind of slowed down oh
well there's the turnover right there
it's getting ready to say nice pass
ahead
zach levine ooh showtime from levine
[Applause]
give you a little highlight reel get
this man back in the dunk contest
i was just thinking that's a have a lot
of
contest
worthy
three possession game zach levine all
the way oh
mitchell robinson
rebound seven assists had been quiet for
most of this fourth quarter
until this jam most improved player
and a first team or a first-time
all-star last year
levine again
that time a little mix-up defensively
offenses or shake your head and talk
about d
but the offenses are getting it done wow
it's act levine we talk about zion and
zach
he just blows right by bulls can go two
for one down the stretch
trailing by two holiday guarding levine
now sabonis
levine step back three for the lead oh
oh stop it zach
big time players make big time plays
double a
so goodness
sets up the one-on-one with carter now
meets more bodies and carter
comes up with a rejection levine in
transition
with the right-handed
he starts teeing it up right here right
here he's looking at wait for that goal
and then the dunk what a finish but he
got his steps right
early he was just waiting for seth curry
to go for that steal
he even look bulls looked to run the
other night against toronto they got out
in transition
oh roby wasn't looking for the ball
sadaransky's got it
go get it oh my flight
eight do you have your ticket
watch this shadow throws it to the rim
fly
young man fly
perfect pass thunderous dunk
a thunder timeout 8-2 start
we talked about it just his usage is
different he's so much more comfortable
another pass assist from young
and the hammer from levine he looks
fresh
this happened so fast we didn't even
catch the culprit he got out of there
quick
who's that guy dumped on oh sorry about
that
keelan martin caleb martin hits the big
time stuff from our friends and points
back
okay
47 right now
who quickly lost confidence on my jumper
oh levine gets the crowd fired up
but zach levine with the highlight
i mean that is just beautiful levine's
played 21 minutes 16 points four
rebounds